Coffee on a Tuesday,
Flanagan second.
What are you doing?
Uh,
I thought I could just do
so.
Maybe you've had this experience before.
You were dreaming something terrible
like you were a little child and your
mother was yelling at you or a giant
evil baby was chasing you or you saw the
death of your wife.
Whatever it is,
you wake up feeling like shit.
You say to yourself,
this is going to be a shitty day.
I just have a feeling.
Then getting out of the shower,
you slip and fall and layer you trip on
the sidewalk and spill your coffee
everywhere and then you do it again.
Your friend calls you and says she can't
make it for lunch.
Your job application comes back,
rejected you burn your hand on the
stove.
There was no toilet paper.
Desperate housewives is a repeat and you
go to bed thinking,
what a shitty day.
I knew it was gonna be shit.
Now.
I think we can see right here that there
was nothing in the physical universe,
which is guaranteeing a bad day for our
friend Justin.
No,
the universe doesn't care what kind of
data is.
It's just another rotation of 360
degrees,
but it's here that Justin decides and
all his infinite wisdom that he's going
to make a prediction about the day to
day is going to be bad and all that bad
stuff really does happen,
so going to bed,
Justin believes that his prediction was
dead on.
This is called a self fulfilling
prophecy,
a false definition of the situation,
evoking new behavior which makes the
originally false definition come
consciously or unconsciously.
Justin created his own bad day,
but he's no different than any of us.
Self fulfilling prophecies are
inexorably weaved into all of our lives
and we go through life thinking that
this is going to be a bad day or I'm
definitely going to get this job or that
student's going to do really well,
or these banks are in trouble,
so I withdraw my money just to be safe.
In every example,
false definitions lead to real outcomes
like a bad day or a good job or a
straight a student or a global
recession,
and the concept is old.
See oedipus Macbeth,
Star Wars,
but the idea of self fulfilling prophecy
has much deeper connotations.
Then Justin's bad day.
Each and every one of our identities
comes into existence by way of them as
cute little infants.
We are psychologically no different from
animals.
We react to the stimuli around us based
on genetic program.
We have no sense of meaning,
no sense of ourselves,
no identity,
but as babies.
Our parents don't treat us like animals.
No,
they treat us like we do have
identities.
They talked to us like we can understand
what they're saying and what they're
saying is basically this,
we love you and you are there.
They show us what it is to be
recognized.
Now,
in order for that recognition to blossom
into a self,
the baby has to be courageous to risk
that first communication,
mom or a dad.
The edit is a risk.
The self is a very tumultuous thing to
have.
It's much easier just to stay silent,
but those good parents have been very
encouraging,
will love you.
No matter what they say will apply to
you or mirror you.
You can trust in this way.
Parents create their children's
identities by way of self fulfilling
prophecy.
They predict the identity and then
organize their behavior so as to bring
it about and the more loving the parent,
the more courageous the baby will be.
Now,
the self is not a prize.
It needs to be worked on all the time
and this too is a constant process of
self fulfilling prophecy.
Social reality is very flexible.
It's subject to a variety of
interpretations.
We define the world and our place in it
every single day and as it was our
parents,
we literally created our identities.
Our conception of how they see us
remains a huge part of ourselves like it
or not.
And it's the same with friends and
lovers.
We are all continuously creating one
another's identities and it's all self
fulfilling prophecy.
Now,
Justin had a bad day.
There's no question about that and it
was self fulfilling prophecy,
but one thing you didn't see was when I
called him after the desperate
housewives disappointment and told them
about my own shitty day and listen to
his getting off the phone.
I said,
don't worry about it,
buddy.
Shit happens.
And you can always vent to me because
I'm sure as hell can.
I've vent to you.
He laughed and got off the phone,
went to his bed and thought,
what a shitty day.
I knew it was going to be Shitty,
but.
Well,
you never know about tomorrow.
Pretty good.
Susan,
what are you doing?
My son,
my son,
I
did.